so I'm gonna talk about self-deploying
applications but we need to understand
why I think it's possible in the NGO
community so one thing that I find
unique of all the runtimes and language
environments that I've used one thing
that makes go unique is this idea of the
go runtime and being a compiled language
allows us to create these self-contained
binaries all right how many people like
this feature of going it's like my
number one feature if you didn't raise
your hand I'm gonna show you why it's
amazing it's simple but it's amazing so
when we think about the point an
application especially a go application
we compile the program we copy the
program to the target system you start
the program there's a bunch of things
that help happen especially if you're
using elf binary we need to get this
thing loaded into memory the kernel
takes over and pass this control to our
program if you come from a different
programming environment it's usually a
lot more steps than that I'm in the girl
world how this is the most beautiful
thing about go Lane crazy statically
linked executables can be done in a
single line like that so here I'm just
going to use this bill script to create
that statically linked self-contained
binary and most of our tools the way we
think about deployment comes from this
particular flow now you build your app
I'm not gonna copy to the other side to
save time it's already there and then I
SSH to a machine and then our goal is to
execute this particular binary all right
it's a very simple binary so we'll jump
on this machine and we'll just run it
okay so this is called hello universe
it's called hello universe because it's
bigger than the world so this is this is
next-level stuff that you're about to
see so what we want to do is we want to
see how this thing works it's a simple
application so I want to hit on this
public IP just to make sure everything
is actually working this is all live so
if anything doesn't work spying up my
fault I need I need the Wi-Fi so now's
not a good time to update your computer
okay
like let me use the Wi-Fi so we hit this
and we'll see we got to test a demo guys
with a small offering okay eighty eighty
all right so far so good
hello universe okay and that's the
process for most go programmers right so
we say hey we have the self-contained
application we're doing great so then we
move into the next question is what
happens when you have more than one
machine all right now this is when it
gets hard anyone ever heard of DevOps ah
so DevOps is group therapy for
developers and cysts that means because
the problem gets super hard when you
have to target multiple machines so in
our case we have a cluster of machines
where a lot of this workflow goes away
so let's get off as a single machine so
what we have is a couple of machines we
have ten of them in this particular
cluster one thing you could do is if
you're a for loop SSH all your binaries
and teach server start them or you can
admit this thing called configuration
management where we have something that
automates that process for the last ten
and fifteen years in in system
administration I haven't really moved
the bar too much just automated this
kind of one single deployment mindset
but one thing we could do is adopt some
things that we find in the container
world right so we're gonna go from the
self-contained binary and then we have
to bring in all this extra tooling so we
can target more machines you haven't
seen this in action what you would
normally need to do is create a docker
file so we need a kind of a resource
envelope to put our self-contained
binary and I'm gonna put it in the box
so then we can use a different tool in
this case you want to use kubernetes to
push our application to all those
machines with very little effort okay so
first thing we need to do is get that
static the link binary we have that
running all right the next thing we need
to do is create this docker file so
we'll do docker build here and what this
will do is take our statically linked
binary and you'll notice that this
docker containers gonna be really really
small because I like to do my build-out
of my container image it's going to push
this up and this will spit out a docker
image okay now the next thing we can do
is we can test docker locally and if it
all works we can push this docker
container to a repository now since my
goal is to support multiple machines are
not a single machine I'm going to use a
cluster manager to do that for us so
what I need to do now is describe what
that looks like so most of these tools
have some way to define your application
so there's that container we just built
and here I'm saying I would like this to
run somewhere in that cluster okay
so we want to take a bunch of machines
and make them look like a single machine
so here I'm going to send this
particular description to kubernetes so
that it can write it for us all right so
we'll create this so what should happen
now if things are working I should have
one of those applications right so
that's my container and let's say I want
to have multiple copies of it so we'll
see what that looks like so this is
great we're learning all this tooling
that allows us to do this thing so we'll
apply these changes great so if I look
at this now we have now 10 copies
running somewhere in our cluster right
this is great now kind of the drawback
here is that I have to learn all this
tooling bring in this container format
even though my binary is self-contained
let's make sure that this is actually
working
it's a KU CTL get SVC now we get a
single IP address that lets me us to
make sure we can actually hit this
alright yep and we see it so each of
these is has its own host name and
network namespace so we can flip through
there and we see that our application is
now running across multiple machines
with little effort now the problem here
though is that you again have to learn
all of this tooling to make that work so
the nice thing about golang is that it's
all self-contained you build the
application and it's easy to deploy so
this quote came from
one of the Google legends or errors and
his fellow author of the data center as
a computer we must treat the data center
itself as one massive warehouse scale
computer so what I just went through was
the idea of doing that taking all of our
machines and make it look like a single
machine but the problem is our
application the benefits we have from
golang are lost in the deployment
process what I would like to have is
that self-contained binary also be
something that can self deploy all right
so what we want to do is start to think
about what does it mean to be a self
deploying application well we know we
need to compile the program that can't
go away the program also needs to be
started but if we're going to think
about the data center of being the
computer then we get a lot more in the
data center we're not dealing with a
single file system or a single POSIX
target so when we say load the program
into memory that can actually be
something that's federated okay we just
need the binary to be available to be
loaded into a machine and then also we
need to challenge the idea of where the
kernel is okay so the kernel in our case
goes from just a single machine to
kubernetes itself the cluster manager
all right so we're going to trade the
syscall interface of a single machine to
the api's of the cluster manager right
and given the current golang runtime all
the things we need to start a process on
a single machine are built in and then
we hand off to the to the kernel so we
can reload it and then it hands it back
to us to do any other syscalls that we
want so we want a very similar flow for
our go binaries all right I don't want
to teach people everything about
kubernetes to do that so let's see what
the world would look like if we had a
binary that could deploy itself okay so
we're gonna go back and remind ourselves
what our current program does so let's
make sure we clean up so we'll delete
this current one RS hello universe all
right so that's cleaned up so let's look
at the application again so we'll just
do go build
and I also don't want to create a
container first I would just like to use
my aesthetic wink binary so the first
thing we want to do let's just do go
install all right so hello universe will
listen to ACP on my local machine and
we're here at 8080
right very simple program just make sure
that it actually works one two it's
seven 8080 all right I'm pretty sure
Google IT is like what the hell are you
doing leaking your host names uh-huh
that we can edit that out Security's
like ah all right so we see this simple
application just works
okay so here's all the logs from it all
make sense so I want to take the same
application but I want it to Diplo
itself so we have all of these nodes but
I don't want to create all the other
stuff that we just went through so it
would be nice if I could teach my
program how to deploy itself all right
so now I have a library called cargo
with a key and cargo gives me all of
these flags if I import that library and
like I fill out a little bit of code and
now I get all of these things to allow
me to express how all I did to be
deployed to the target system
now the cluster that I want to deploy to
doesn't currently have my go binary and
I don't want to build a docker container
and there's some tricks we do underneath
the covers so here what I want to do
here is going to enable kubernetes and
also I'm going to say how many copies I
want so you can think about this of how
many threads would you like to run
except in this case or go routines and
stuff in this case I'm gonna have
multiple containers running throughout a
cluster so here we'll say replicas equal
someone gave me a number
[Music]
we'll take 10 this guy's 20,000 he's
that's the person that wants you to fail
your live demo failure alright so here's
what we want to do so we want to do is
target a cluster so I'm going to run my
client a command line so I can actually
choose what cluster I want okay so I'm
gonna run this now so the first thing I
need to do since I'm on a oh s X I can't
run this mock binary in my cluster so I
need to compile a version of myself that
will work at the target once I have that
I take the shot 256 and I load it into
memory in this case this is going to be
a Google file storage bucket and once
it's there I'm going to copy those
things up and make accessible in the
cluster and then what I'm going to do is
go take all 10 of those processes that
are running somewhere in the cloud and
grab their logs okay so what should
happen now is if I go back and I look at
that service endpoint we should be able
to see what happens okay so we come here
and we'll get some traffic and what
you'll see is that my application is
proxying all of those logs back to my
standard console and if we look inside
of our datacenter computer here whose
CTO get pods will see that they're all
deployed ok so while my application is
running it launched itself into this
data center as a computer and if I were
to exit out of this application you
catch your shutdown signals and your
goal is to clean up after yourself we
want we don't want to orphan any
processes so now if I look at this we
see all the pods are gone so we're just
treating these targets just like a
single machine ok so when we think about
this we can actually go and keep that
same self-contained feel that we have in
golang but target any computer even this
idea of
the data center being the computer but
then here's a quote of mine
alright just now
so we're in this cloud world now and
even for the smaller startup people
assume that your application will be
available globally right so it's no
longer acceptable to have it in one data
center so now I'm saying we should treat
the world itself as one massively global
scale computer all right so what does
that look like so imagine the world now
this is where we get to a highly
experimental I'm gonna give you a
warning the demo guys have been nice but
we're about to tempt them a little more
so let's say clusters list let's make
sure we spell things right it's a
container I love it when they pay
attention so we have three clusters okay
for those of you that can't read that's
Asia Europe and the US and this is where
it really gets challenging okay how now
do you target all three of these
clusters and get the behavior that you
want we don't want to go through the
process that we saw before so in this
new global computer we actually have a
different interface called Federation
this is where we take multiple clusters
and make them look like a single cluster
and we get the same benefits that we
have with the cluster that made a bunch
of machines look like a single machine
and now let's look at what it takes for
our process to run in that context okay
so we want to do the same thing how many
copies should we run 50 someone set 50
this is like not working territory but
you know that's up to ante I will do 50
see as a speaker you have an opportunity
to go back and do something sane but you
don't alright let's make sure whatever
all right so our goal is to run in all
the clusters and let's see what we get
so we're building the binary we want to
make sure it's re so here's our output
it's already there we're creating a
replica set and then now our goal is to
see if we do have a global deployed
application so we'll say in the context
of EU things are happening okay and the
context of the u.s. things are running
and the context of Asia running let's go
back to the EU
and let's see if it's real and in order
to have a global computer we need a
global naming service right so what
we'll do is we'll grab any of these
we'll grab this one which will proxy our
traffic over every computer in our
global namespace let's see if it works
I'm dropping the mic on that one that's
it we have a woven industry the
application